some of our favorite reality TV couples
love a good meal whether it's an on
camera date or when they're on vacation
we learned that when we teamed up with
secrets resorts and spas for a week of
gourmet dining it's unlimited luxury
[Music]
heaven Carly amazing
Enrique amazing room service thank you
so much you guys are the success story
out of reality TV
what is the secrets about we just serve
have fun and we're like kind of doing
our own thing in Nashville for this
normal-people
guys I cannot think of a better place to
have lunch these views are unbelievable
as we've been on this trip I've noticed
people come up to you constantly hey
what do they ask you more than anything
for pictures the number one question we
get is is it real cheers guys the secret
to your relationship is friends first
then you fell in love when did you know
that things have turned romantic oh when
do they turn romantic new your chili
once you're told me my feelings yes well
let's get you a special night out dinner
overlooking the water
over it here we go thank you
Oh steak and lobster well certain so
much
[Applause]